Musik Ist jetzt wie ein Arschloch zu klingen? Um das zu vermeiden, werd ich's einfach mal sehen. Ich weiss, es hat keiner nach gefragt, aber ich mag's am liebsten, wenn ihr sagt. Was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for production, was for schicken jedem von euch nochmal ein Handout, was hier gerade gerappt wurde, in halsbrecherischer Geschwindigkeit von Michel. Vielen, vielen Dank an Michel, er sitzt heute am Tisch, aber natürlich auch mir gegenüber. Stefan Tietzer, aka The Tetzler, aka Lenny The Pip, aka Please Don't Let Me Be Misunderstood. Er ist hier. Hallo. Ja, herzlich willkommen auch an Florentin. Was ihr nicht wisst, dass immer die Leute, die das Intro mitgeschickt haben, bei uns am Tisch noch sitzen. Genau. Es ist, manche sagen unhöflich von uns, kein Mikro hinzustellen, manche sagen aber sehr höflich, weil andere Podcasts würden die gar nicht einladen erst. Bei uns sitzen die immer schweigen gegenüber und können sich das mit Tag lang gucken. Bzw. sie reden schon mit, aber da sie kein Mikrofon haben, wird das einfach nicht aufgezeichnet. Niemand kriegt es mit, wir reden auch ständig rein, es ist sehr unangenehm. Michel, vielen, vielen Dank, und er hat angemerkt, dass sein Name noch nie als Intro gefallen ist. Also haben wir es hier mit Michel1 zu tun. Ja, weil er wahrscheinlich Michael heißt und einfach das A. Michel und er ist Michel1 und das finde ich, sollte man auch mal guttieren. Also hier guttiert Michel vielen, vielen Dank an die Welt des Hip-Hop, die wir immer gerne bereisen, immer gerne mal safariartig in einem gut gesicherten Jeep durchfahren, aber dann auch wieder nach Hause fahren. Genau, und wenn es so nahe kommt ans Jeepauto, ans Safariauto, dann werde ich nervös und bitte den Fahrer, der auch nicht meine Sprache spricht, doch ein bisschen schneller zu fahren. Und ich bin aber ganz froh aus dieser Binocular-Entfernung, ein bisschen Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einer Art, in einerabiert wird, ich sag mal in so einem Popsong wie in einem Ari, SP, CT, komme ich so gerade hinterher. Ich bräuchte so ein kurzes Stopp, so, zehn Sekunden Pause. Ari, SP, aber da geht es ja noch, die lassen ja einem ja Zeit und die wiederholen es, weil es Popsongs sind. Bei Rap wird die ganze Zeit durchgespittet und dann zwischendurch, wenn ich nicht wüsste, wie der Name dieses Projektes heisst,
hätte ich nicht gewusst, was er buchstabiert. Ich glaube, es war Podcast-UFO.
Ich glaube auch, dass es bei so Rap-Battles, wo sich die Lines hin und her droppen, viele auch sagen, ich bin kurz ausgestiegen.
Sorry, ich bin kurz ausgestiegen, ich habe mich nicht verstanden.
I zoned out a little.
Ich war kurz gedanklich ganz kurz woanders und habe 30 Zeilen verpasst in dem Moment. Kannst du es kurz noch zusammenfassen, damit ich was Heisses darauf spitten kann? Ja, ich habe jetzt durchgebinged, was ich sehr empfehlen kann, Love on the Spectrum auf Netflix. Hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht, fand ich toll. Eine Sendung, die sich mit dem Liebesleben von Leuten on the spectrum befasst, in Australien spielt das. und ja alles inien, aber es hört man, ich weiß nicht, ob du Scherze gemacht hast, weil es ruft, es alles ruft Australien, der Akzent vor allem, schreit, schreit die ins Gesicht in Australien, doch auf jeden Fall und ich, also ich habe das sehr genossen, vor allem, also na klar, jetzt guckt man das dann und jeder bezieht ein bisschen was auf sich und so, aber es ist eine sehr liebevolle Art, finde ich, wie diesen Menschen begegnet wird und wie es erklärt wird. Und was ich ganz toll fand, dass zwischendurch einfach sie gesagt haben, ganz ehrlich, sorry I sound out a little bit, wenn man so eine Frage gestellt hat beim ersten Date irgendwie wie, wo kommst du her und die andere Person erklärt das dann, sagt die andere Person, sorry, I sound out a little bit. Und mir gefällt das ganz gut, einfach zu sagen, sorry, das ging mir viel zu lange. Aber ich habe es so ein paar ausgedrückt und so, und klar, on the spectrum, dann ist man den Leuten noch nicht sauer, wenn sie dann sagen, sorry, I sound out a little bit. Und man denkt, ja, okay, kein Problem. Signallose Ehrlichkeit, das ist eigentlich ganz gut. Da kann man sich was von abschneiden, hier und da. Ich würde auch gerne ab und zu einfach mal sagen, Sound out. Apropos Dating und Leute kennenlernen, ich habe mir letztens überlegt, das Nervigste an Dates ist ja, irgendjemand muss die Verantwortung übernehmen, eine Location zu bestimmen. Man kennt sich in der Stadt nicht aus, ich persönlich kenne nur meine Wohnung und den Edeka, das war's, ab und zu den Bahnhof, alles drei aus unterschiedlichen Gründen sehr schlechte Orte. Bahnhof ist ein sehr guter Ort, eigentlich um zu treffen, weil wenn es schief geht, also du bist so schnell so weit weg. Das stimmt, du kannst schnell Abstand nehmen. Du bist acht Stunden in Lissabon und siehst von dem Typen nie wieder was. Und wenn es gut läuft, ist man von Köln sehr schnell in Paris. Das stimmt, da kann man direkt sagen, bist du bereit für die Stadt der Liebe in drei, zwei, eins, los. Ja, gut, ich finde Subway im Bahnhof eigentlich gerade die beste Idee der Welt. Und du hast den Bockwurstmeister auch direkt um die Ecke. Ja, genau. Also da hat der Köln-Hauptbahnhof wunderbar was zu bieten. Du hast diese drei Locations, Edeka natürlich auch immer und dann zu Hause will man vielleicht auch nicht das erste Mal. Deswegen dachte ich, warum b nicht in tinder direkt eine funktion ein wenn man chattet sofort give me a location give me a date so generier mir jetzt ein date dass niemand die verantwortung übernehmen muss das zu entscheiden sondern einfach entweder man swip gemeinsam date location ideen also man geht dann in eine swipe in zweiter ordnung rein dass man gemeinsam sagtushi, hast du Lust auf Hafenspaziergang, je nachdem, wo man ist, kann man natürlich auch mit Restaurants, Bars kooperieren, die natürlich da Angebote machen, die dann irgendwie Datepaare, die richtig Bock haben, diese unangenehmen, schweigenden, schwitzenden Datepaare bei sich zu haben, die vielleicht einen kleinen Cappuccino bestellen, sonst nichts, sondern gehen. Und deswegen dachte ich, warum das nicht direkt einbauen? Ich fand es super, ein Restaurant bei Love on the Spectrum hat gesagt, für Dates gibt es diesen extra Plate. Oh Gott! Und dann kam eine Kellnerin an, die gesagt hat, ihr habt ja ein Date. Dann hat sie den beiden Girls in dem Fall so einen Platten gestellt mit sehr vielen Gebäckteilchen. Aber das fand ich super. Ich finde das grauenvoll. Die, das fand ich fantastisch. Sie sind jetzt im Date an einem grossen Herztisch mit Rosenblüten drauf. Und so gleißend hellen Wunderkerzen, die Funken sprühen und die Tischdecke brennt. Und so der Eingang zum Darkroom, direkt daneben. Direkt daneben, wo lautes Stöhnen rausdröhnt. Super. Ich finde, das ist aber gut. Wir programmieren Tinder um. Die App heißt das Podcast-Sufo, aber das gehört jetzt hier nicht hin. Nee, das gehört wirklich hier nicht hin. Und dann quasi, wenn du ein Match hast, kommst du in ein weiteres System mit Leuten. Und dann siehst du deine Girls wieder, mit denen du ein Match hattest. Und dann geht es oben aber nicht mehr um Obländigkeit und wie man sich gefällt optisch, sondern jetzt geht es um, wo trifft man sich denn da. Genau, und du siehst dann einmal Bianca im Fischrestaurant, dann siehst du Paula, romantischer Spaziergang. Schlecht ausgeschnitten. Genau, automatisch ausgeschnitten. Am Bahnhofsgebäude. Genau, Paula am Bahnhof, Rebecca im Park, Spaziergang und dann kannst du noch mal da
swipen, ob du darauf lustig hättest.
Und du musst vorher anklicken, was du willst.
Weil dein Face muss ja auch...
Wenn du Paula im Park gerecht swiped hast
und sie Stefan im Park gerecht
swiped hat, dann gibt es noch mal ein Match
zweiter Ordnung, Paula und Stefan
im Park.
Also da kann man nur noch mal
weitermachen. Oder wie wäre es denn da kann man dann noch mal weitermachen.
Oder wie wäre es denn, wenn man dann so ein langes Formular bekommt, was funktioniert wie so ein Google-Doodle, wo man sehr viele Sachen ankreuzen kann und es werden Überschneidungen gefunden. Man kriegt aus dembei so einen Zettel per Post, per Briefpost zugeschickt, wo draufsteht so gemeinsame Interessen, die detected wurden, die man vielleicht mal ansprechen kann. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich bin bei Doodle immer der Erste einträgt.
Und manchmal warte ich absichtlich, damit ich nicht der Erste bin,
damit ich nicht wie der krasse Streber aussehe.
Weil es immer so eine Gruppe von zehn Leuten,
hey Leute, schreibt mir in Doodle, wann ihr könnt.
Und ich so, ja okay, mache ich sofort.
Wirklich jetzt?
Ja, da bin ich dann wirklich sofort dabei. Nee, da bin ich der Letzte, was ich nicht verstehe,
weil wir darüber gesprochen haben letzte Woche,
dass du deine Briefe nicht aufmachst.
Nee, nee, jeder hat ja die gleiche Geschwindigkeit.
Die Frage ist nur, wie man sie einsetzt. Jeder hat ja die gleiche Anzahl an Geschwindigkeitspunkten. Und ich habe halt ganz viel gespart bei Rechnungen. Und dafür habe ich fast alles auf Doodle gesetzt. Ob das so clever war, weil Doodle ganz am Ende war, habe ich keine Punkte mehr über. Doch, ich hatte alle noch übrig. Ich habe nicht gespielt. Und da dachte ich mir, jetzt muss ich sie alle in Doodle stecken. Und deswegen bin ich da immer sofort. Aber manchmal will ich absichtlich warten, bis dann schon jemand gemacht hat, damit ich nicht immer ganz oben bin, damit nicht alle sehen, oh, der hat anscheinend ganz viel Zeit. Und ich glaube, das kennen wir auch alle, bei Doodle weniger Zeit angeben, als man tatsächlich hat. Einfach weil man nicht sagen will, ja, ich habe eigentlich die nächsten zwei Wochen jede Minute Zeit. Und dann fängt man dann irrational aus anzuklicken, sowas wie, ne, Donnerstags geht's ja schon Richtung Wochenende. Ich lasse mal deswegen, obwohl ich an jedem Donnerstag perfekt Zeit hätte, lasse ich meine Donnerstage weg. Dieser Fantasieslot immer Dienstag 14 bis 18 Uhr kann ich gar nicht, kann ich überhaupt nicht. Man fängt an, sich Ründe auszudenken, da könnte man ja mal und sowas. Und dann alle können Dienstags, nur ich nicht und dann muss man leider darauf beruhen, nee, da bin ich leider beim Padel. Big Reveal, ich sabotiere bei Doodle. Bei Treffen, und das ist sehr cool, das ist ein sehr gutes Tool dafür, wenn man jetzt ungeliebte Treffen, auf die man nicht so Lust hat, kann man ganz einfach zum Verschwinden, zum Platzen bringen, indem man ganz lange wartet und dann der Letzte ist, der einträgt und sich nur an die Punkte einträgt, wo niemand kann. Oder nur einer kann. Das ist so wie bei vier Gewinn, wenn du den letzten Zug machen kannst und dir genau auswählst, wo du dir hinwirst. Richtig, richtig. Du kannst am Ende hast du dieses große, diese Matrix vor dir, dieses große Sudoku-Feld und du kannst hier absichtlich sabotieren, dass das Treffen nicht stattfindet. Weil du an keinem Punkt, wo drei von vier schon können, drehst du nicht nach. Das sieht gut aus für Mittwoch 18 Uhr, bis der Titzler kommt. Bis der Titzler kommt. Titzler kann da gar nicht. Ich kann leider da überhaupt nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Gar nicht. Leider gar nicht. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Nee, bei mir ist, bei Date-Locations finde ich ja immer Home-Places nehmen. Cafes, die man kennt zum Beispiel. Das liebe ich ja. Ich kenne kein einziges Café. Cafes, wo man schon mal war. Deswegen glaube ich, das ist ein sehr spezielles Problem, was du hast, dass du halt nur den Edeka kennst, aber auch spannend, übrigens auch lustig, wenn man da, wenn sie versteht, den Gag versteht, dass du nur drei Orte kennst und deswegen geht den Edeka für das erste Date. Du, ich finde ohnehin, zusammen einkaufen ist mit das Beste, was man machen kann. Teste sofort alles aus. Teste sofort alles aus, natürlich jetzt in der Situation vielleicht nicht ideal, aber so allein die Gespräche, die vorm Erdnussbutterregal entstehen, waren für mich immer am enthüllsten eigentlich. Erstmal immer mehr. Okay, nee, da will man nicht weitermachen oder da lohnt sich was. Okay, wir reenacten mal das typische Gespräch am Erdnussbutterregal. So, kommen wir zum Thema Erdnussbutter. Erst mal, wow, dass die hier ein Erdnussbutterregal haben. Das habe ich so in Deutschland nie gesehen. Ja, das ist richtig krass. Die haben hier unten extra in der Ecke noch mal Erdnussbutter. Deswegen sind wir hier hingegangen und nicht in irgendeinem Supermarkt. Woher wusstest du, dass ich das mag? Du magst Erdnussbutter? Ja, ich liebe Erdnussbutter. Wirklich? Ja. Und welche Art? Eher crunchy oder eher smooth? Und das ist immer so, auch bei Love on the Spectrum. Sie haben immer Sachen, die sie ganz doll mögen und Sachen, die sie gar nicht doll mögen, also hassen, um nicht zu sagen. Und man sieht immer anhand des Gesichtes, was von beiden man genommen hat. Dann stellen sie einem entweder Oder-Fragen und dann dann war ... Michael zum Beispiel, ich liebe Michael, hat gefragt, hast du Kinder? Und sie hat gesagt ja und sein Gesicht sagt oh. Und man merkt als Gegenüber, fuck, falsche Antwort. Da wird nichts versteckt, da wird nichts überspielt, da kriegt man direkt die Antwort. Ja genau, deswegen, okay, ähm, creamy, ich liebe creamy, but, erhält das Butter.
Oh du, ich hab noch, plötzlich fällt mir, ich hab noch einen ganz dringenden Termin leider.
Ich hab noch beim Schulladen muss ich mir noch meine Füsse vermessen.
Das passt total, ich muss auch zum Fussvermessen stehen.
Nee, das ist blöd, weil da gab's ja jetzt diesen Fussz-Vorfall und deswegen darf man da nicht zu zweit rein und deswegen glaube ich, wäre es besser, wenn dann, also, ja, vielleicht nächste Woche, dann, wir gehen nochmal in ein Dudel und trag ein und dann, weil wäre es, also smoother Erdnisbutter, das ist wirklich, also sorry. Aber danke, dass du mich eingeleladen hast, hier in den Edeka. Ja klar, du, behalte die Papri-Sonne und dann bis ... Jo, ciao, ciao. Und dann steht man noch an der Kasse eine Stunde lang an. Und das finde ich ist bei Love on the Spectrum das Beste überhaupt, deswegen habe ich auch überlegt, an der Datingshow teilzunehmen, weil sie am Ende immer in andere Richtungen müssen. Genau. Sie verabschieden sich und noch nie mussten die, und die Dates sind oft peinlich und es wird nicht so viel gesagt und ein bisschen hölzern. Das ist ja auch ein bisschen dann die Idee. Das ist auch natürlich die Frage, wie cool macht man sich da, macht man sich nicht doch ein bisschen lustig. Andere Diskussionen, aber sie kriegen es hin, dass sie am Ende nie in die gleiche Richtung nach Hause müssen. Das ist das eigentliche Wunder dieser Sendung. Nicht, dass sie Liebe finden, sondern dass sie tatsächlich nie in die gleiche Richtung laufen müssen. Machst du das extra, dass du immer den Mailton anlässt? Nee, ich vergesse es nur immer. Damit quasi Leute hören, wie viele Mails du bekommst und wie wahnsinnig beliebt du bist. Und dann machst du es aus und dann zehn Minuten später in der Folge kriegst du nochmal eine Mail. Aber ich krieg nur Spam, ich krieg wirklich konstant nur Spam. Hier zum Beispiel Verbraucherhilfe24 habe ich gerade bekommen, wie Dieselfahrer Schadensersatz bekommen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob man über diese Mail stolz sein kann, aber es ist einfach nur Spam. Aber du bist ein spannendes Targetgroup offensichtlich. Ja, bin ich tatsächlich. Ich hatte ganz lange Taschenlampen. Jede erdenkliche Taschenlampenform habe ich beworben bekommen durch Spam. Immer mit 30 Meter Lichtstrahl, erhellt, taghell. Ja gut, dann könnte ich sagen, das ist zu hell. Das ist einfach so ein ... Warum denkt ihr, dass ich eine Taschenlampe brauche? Aber 30 Meter ... weil wenn es innerhalb ... guck mal, wenn man auf der Straße steht und 30 Meter von dir entfernt, macht jemand die iPhone-Lampe an. Siehst du ja. Sind das 30 Meter Licht? Nee, nee, du kannst, wenn du selber die Lampe hast, 30 Meter weit gucken. Gucken, ja, wenn du, ja. Aber wann kann ich denn nicht reich? Also es geht um die Ecke, dann nicht. Aber ansonsten kannst du 30 Meter in die Stanz gucken. Ist zumindest das Versprechen, ob das stimmt oder nicht, weiß ich nicht, aber ich würde mir immer wünschen, mal irgendwie zumindest also das ist ja die uncoolste, wer irgendjemanden kriegen kann, eine Taschenlampe. Was ich mir jetzt besorgt habe, ist eine Heissluft- Fritteuse. Also du, aber thematisch zieht sich Heissluft bei dir ein bisschen durch, ne? Also deine Faszination für Heissluft bei uns. Ich liebe Heiße Luft, ich liebe es einfach. Dieser Podcast ist zu 100 Prozent Heiße Luft und dann, wow, Heißluft-Peteuse. Ich mag's. Wie gut sind die genau? Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber anscheinend hat es irgendein Genie geschafft, kochendes Fett durch heißes Wasser zu ersetzen, heiße Luft zu ersetzen, was ich finde, wow! Also ich meine, es gibt keinen grösseren Unterschied in dieser Welt zwischen kochendem, reinem Fett und Luft. Was Kalorien angeht, was Verfügbarkeit angeht, was Handhabung angeht, es gibt keine grösseren Widersprüche als die beiden Faktoren. Und irgendjemand hat gesagt, warte mal wir mit heißem kochenden Fett, was einfach Schweinen aus dem Bauch gesaugt wurde, machen können, schaffen wir auch mit Luft. Ja. Weiter. So, das heißt, du machst jetzt eine Pommes, also du legst eine Kartoffel. Eine Pommes, ja. Eine kleine Pomme legst du rein in das, was ist das, ein mikrowellenartiges Gefällt. Es ist ein kleiner Ofen. Im Grunde arbeitet ein Ofen auch mit heisser Luft. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Heissluftfritteuse und Ofen? Ist kleiner. Es ist ein bisschen kleiner. Und was ist der Unterschied zwischen Mikrowelle? Eine Mikrowelle funktioniert immer ganz anders. Ja, aber jetzt erklären wir mal, wie eine Mikrowelle funktioniert. Ja, die wabbelt da die Strahlen rein und dass die Wassermoleküle wackeln und werden heiß. Wir machen jetzt nochmal, kennst du dieses tolle YouTube-Format, wo Leute, die Ahnung haben, etwas erst Kleinkindern erzählen müssen und dann Schülern und dann Forschern auf dem gleichen Level. Genau, man guckt immer, wie weit kommt man mit. Ja, genau. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin sehr früh raus. Sehr, sehr früh raus. So, jetzt bin ich ein Kleinkind und du musst mir jetzt Mikrowellen erklären. Ja. Hi! Hallo! Erstmal, wie kriegen die Kleinkinder dazu? Locken die da hin? Okay, erklär mir das. Also, ähm ... Mir ist langweilig. Okay, ja, ja, ganz kurz, ganz kurz. Ich kann mich hier schneiden, aber also, wenn du jetzt was essen willst, die Mikrowelle, guck mich mal ganz kurz an. Ich bin, mag nicht mehr. Leg mal ganz kurz den Stift weg. Ja. Guck mich mal ganz kurz an. Ich bin Wissenschaftler. Okay. Okay, also, du weißt ja, dass in deinem ... Können wir Paw Patrol gucken? Nee, gleich, gleich. Hör mir ganz kurz zu und wenn du es verstanden hast, dann schauen wir eine Folge Paw Patrol, okay? Okay, ganz kurz. Können sie sich um mir ... Ich weiß nicht. Stolze Mutter steht im Hintergrund und will nicht eingreifen und grinst einfach nur doll und sagt, ne, ne. Also, stell dir vor, dass in deinem Essen Wasser drin ist und wenn du das in die Mikrowelle tust, dann wird an dem Wasser geschüttelt durch Wellen.
Und dadurch wird das warm. Ah, deswegen ist unsere Katze gestorben in der Mikrowelle. Ja, das kann gut sein. Wenn die zu heiß ist, dann stirbt die leider. Und wie wird das Wasser warm gemacht? Stell dir vor, du hast so eine Angel mit einer Schnur dran und die Schnur wirfst du an das Wasser und dann wackelst du mit der Schnur und dadurch wird das Wasser gewackelt. Okay, Teenager. Elektromagnetische Wellen ist ein Thema. Ich will gar nicht hier sein. Okay, alles klar. Ich will auch nicht hier sein. Entschuldigung, aber wir müssen jetzt einfach durch, okay? Okay. Hör mir fünf Minuten zu und dann schauen wir eine Folge vor. Ja, okay, Boomer. Was hat denn das jetzt damit zu tun, diese Technik, die ist ... Naja, okay, von mir aus. Also, elektromagnetische Wellenstrahlung ist ja ein Thema bei dir. Was? Alter, nein, was? Ist kein Thema bei mir. Cringe, Alter, cringe. Okay, also, stell dir vor, dein Muffin, das ist wie so ein Moshpit. Ja, wir sagen Cupcakes. Okay. Stell dir vor, du hast ein Cupcake und das ist wie so ein großes Konzert mit Leuten, okay? Nice, ja, nice. Und jetzt, wenn die Musik angeht, dann fangen die alle an zu tanzen. Yes. Die haben richtig Bock, ja, das ist Moshpit und die tanzen. Und dadurch wird es richtig warm und heiß, dadurch, dass die sich alle bewegen. Nice. Und die Mikrowellen, das ist so wie die Musik. Was für eine Musik? Gib mir Referenzen, die ich verstehe. Naja, halt sowas wie Britney Spears. Nein, falsch. Die, die, die, die, hier, James, ähm. James Blunt? Sowas wie Falco. Na, also wo die jungen Leute... Sorry, kann ich gar nicht mit Relaten gerade, ey. Nee, ich verliere mich hier gerade voll, Alter. Aber du verstehst ja die Musik, ist ja egal. Ja, nee, aber so Boomer-Referenzen, so verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Und dann schalte ich auch sofort ab, weil ich habe die Aufmerksamkeit und Spannung von zwei Jahren.
The Weekend. Ja, okay. Okay, ja, ja, nice.
The Weekend, alter, mega. Ja, okay. Cool, Mann, ey, was geht, cool. Hast du, wollen wir mal abhängen oder so?
Nee, erzähl mir weiterhin, wie es funktioniert. Also dann geht die Musik an und alle tanzen und dadurch wird dein Cupcake warm.
Ah, geil. Okay, nice, cool, neat, englisch.
Okay, ja, mega, geil, geil. Okay. Nice. Cool. Neat. Englisch. Okay. Ja, mega. Geil. Geil. Nice one. Hi, ich habe einen PhD in Mikrowellen. Das passt gut. Und ja, ich freue mich auf das Format. Erklär mir, wie Mikrowellen funktionieren. Teach me, wie Mikrowellen funktionieren. Okay, du hast schon drei Masterarbeiten darin geschrieben. Genau, du scheinst ja schon viel zu wissen über das Thema. Was du vielleicht noch nicht weißt, ist, dass wir ... Entschuldigung, kann der Jugendliche noch mal kommen? Kannst du das vielleicht erklären? Ja, es ist halt wie bei so einem Weekend-Konzert. Okay, wie ein Weekend-Konzert. Ja, es ist wie ein Weekend-Konzert. Und wo ... Ey, es werden alle so schnell, wenn alle mingeln und sich voll auf die Musik committen und dann einfach abtanzen und dann geil wärmer. Könnt ihr mal leise sein, ich will Paw Patrol anschauen. Und am Ende schauen alle Paw Patrol und haben einfach eine Freude. Am Ende schauen alle Paw Patrol again und ich frage mich, wie kriegen die überhaupt jemanden dazu, Experten dazu mitzumachen? Eigentlich wäre die bessere Idee ja, dass der Experte es dem Kind erklärt und das Kind erklärt es dem Jugendlichen und der Jugendliche erklärt es dem Erwachsenen und der dem Experten. Und der Experte muss dann wieder dem Ersten erklären und dann muss der vortragen, was erklärt wurde. So lange im Kreis. Ah, herrlich, grossartig. Aber es stimmt schon, da würde es sich wahrscheinlich zeigen, dass man zwar die ganze Zeit genickt hat, aber es nicht nacherzählen könnte. Aber noch geiler wäre das Video rückwärts. Das quasi zuerst erklärt dir jemand, was komplett weird ist. Und dann kommt heraus, wie das zustande gekommen ist. Ja, genau. Das ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Genau. Und dann kommt es zurück und am Ende, nee, wir wollten Mikrowellen erklären. Aber am Ende erklärt dir ein erwachsener Experte, reverse engineered, was Mikrowellen machen. Ich hatte nie eine Mikrowelle. Naja, auch nicht mehr jetzt. Ich hatte lange, als ich in meine erste Studentenwohnung gezogen bin, hier in Köln hatte ich eine Mikrowelle und die war ständig in Benutzung. Ekliges Ding, ekliges Konstrukt, weil du machst ja Mikrowellen auch nicht, also ich habe die nicht sauber gemacht, die war einfach, irgendwann war die so eine Bolognese Tropfsteinhöhle von innen, aber I don't know, also ich habe jetzt mittlerweile keine mehr und ich vermisse die auch gar nicht. Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es jetzt mit meiner Heißluftfritteuse aussieht, ich kann da gerne Feedback geben, ob sich das lohnt, ob das die nächste Mikrowelle ist, aber ich bin sehr gespannt, allein dieses Versprechen, dass man mit heisser Luft so viel machen kann, ich bin sehr bekannt, ich bin sehr... Seitdem du gesagt hast, es ist quasi wie ein Ofen, finde ich es so langweilig, dass du die jetzt kaufst. Naja, naja, also Ofen ist schon so eine Schublade, du hast schon dieses friteuse Feeling so ein bisschen. Aber schmeckt es danach frittiert? Nein. Das weiß ich nicht. Ich werde das alles testen, ich werde da alles Mögliche reinhauen und ich bin ja auch experimentierfreudig, also ich werde dann auch mal gucken, was lässt sich alles frittieren, kann ich da meine Kleidung trocknen, was geht, was nicht und ich werde da wirklich alles reinstecken, was ich habe. Also, ich gehe da bis zum Ende. Ich gehe bis zum Ende. Die Wissenschaft darf an keiner Grenze Halt machen. Außer wenn deine eigene Gesundheit in Gefahr ist. Nein, auch da nicht? Zweifel zwei musst du selber die Medizin schlucken, um zu testen, ob es klappt. Ja, okay, alles klar. Das ist die Wissenschaft. Es gibt einen ganzen Friedhof für Wissenschaftler, die an ihren eigenen Experimenten zugrunde gegangen sind. Aber am Ende brauchst du jemanden, das testen. Schreibt in die Kommentare, was ihr wollt, dass Florentin in seinen Heissluftballon stecken soll, und dann gucken wir mal. Dann kannst du jede Woche erklären, was passiert ist.
Finde ich nicht so schlecht.
Ich habe nach wie vor Heissluftballons, ich habe ein Video geguckt,
ich wollte eigentlich nur mal wieder gucken,
GoPro on an Eagle.
Und fand es cool.
Und dann war es GoPro on an Eagle above Vienna,
was ich noch cooler fand, weil ich kenne Wien. Und ich dachte mir, what? Und dann GoPro, das einzige, was es dazu gab zu diesem Thema, war es GoPro on an Eagle over Vienna from a Heissluftballon. Und dann ist ein Heissluftballon gestartet und dann haben die den mitgenommen und haben die von oben losgelassen. Ich habe nicht den Mehrwert dieses Heissluftballons verstanden, weil das Spannende an einem Adler ist ja,
dass der schon von sich aus fliegen kann.
Aber irgendwie haben die den auf den Heißluftballon gesetzt
und den Heißluftballon ist nach oben gestrungen
und dann haben die den von da fliegen lassen.
Was auch ein bisschen eine ungemeine Aktion ist,
den einfach in tausend Meter Höhe zu verfrachten.
Und der so, jetzt muss ich wieder runterfliegen, oder was?
Es ist ein Showoff auch.
Wir Menschen können das auch. Wir brauchen jetzt nicht einen Flügel, also wir haben auch selber Möglichkeiten in die Luft zu steigen. Ja. Fand ich merkwürdig, aber spannendes Video, und da ist mir wieder aufgefallen, das heißt doch bei uns, der will ja einfach am seidenen Faden hängen. Ja. Also nicht nur wortwörtlich, das sind vier seidene Fäden, ich verstehe auch nicht, warum man das nimmt, als Material, aber der Korb hängt ja nur an kleinen Fäden an dem Ballon. Und der Ballon ist ja auch nichts anderes als ein sehr langer geflochtener Seidenfaden, wo Feuer reinsteigt. Und ich denke immer, wenn da ein Windzug kommt, weil die haben ja diesen riesigen Bunsenbrenner am Start, der zwischendurch Feuer da rein spuckt, damit die Luft oben heiß bleibt. Ja. Und mal vor, kommt ein Windstoss und diese hauchzarte Wand dieses Luftballons wird angegriffen von dem Feuer, ist doch sofort tot. Dann fällst du Kilometer in die Tiefe, grauenvoll. Ja, vielleicht hat man nach dem Hindenburg-Unfall gedacht, nehmen wir feuerresistentes Material, aber vielleicht auch nicht. Ich weiß es nicht, wie oft man da tatsächlich rangeht, aber es stimmt.
Es ist wirklich auch mein Horrorszenario.
Mein Horrorszenario ist auch,
dass man da nicht mehr runterkommt einfach.
Also, dass man irgendwie
starke Aufwinde
und dann zu viel Feuer und dann
will man das nicht kaputt machen.
Das war immer meine Angst.
Ich habe ja gewohnt neben dem Weltballon in Berlin.
Da gab es den großen Weltballon mit Helium. Und der Und der, halt Helium, so der steigt ja schon eine Weile hoch. Und der hatte aber immer so ein Drahtseil unten, so dass der an einem Drahtseil befestigt hochgeflogen ist und dann mit dem Drahtseil wieder runtergezogen ist. Ja. Und ich hatte jedes Mal, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, diese Bilder im Kopf, dass ich das Drahtseil abschneide und dann einfach guck, was passiert. Weil über Berlin hast du plötzlich zehn Touristen in einem Heliumluftballon, die einfach drohen, in die Stratosphäre zu geraten. Das ist aber ein Film. Sandra Bullock ist oben als Luftballon im Helium Ballon über Berlin, weil so ein Terrorist, weil Cyrus Snape unten, ich weiß den Namen vergessen, des Schauspielers, der kann auch nicht mehr mitspielen, Alan Rickman hat unten das Abgeschnitten. Genau, Alan Rickman mit so einem Drahtschere schneidet das durch und vor allem was passiert dann? Irgendwann wird die Politikerin, dann kommt da ein Hubschrauber oder kommen Abfangjäger, die dann den abschießen. Die was machen? Abschießen oder abschießen oder drücken. Dann Hubschrauber, genau, von oben drückt ein Hubschrauber das wieder runter. Keine Ahnung, was passiert. Aber da habe ich mir immer gedacht, eines Tages mache ich das mal. Irgendwann, ich glaube mittlerweile ist der Ballung kaputt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall. Warum? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was passiert ist, ich wohne ja nicht mehr, also falls jemand ein Update hat, bitte gerne her damit. Aber es ist ein furchteinflussendes Thema, dieses man steigt und steigt und kommt nicht mehr runter, das finde ich schon
unangenehm. Da dreht sich bei mir
alles um. Aber deswegen,
aber du hast recht, feuerresistentes Material bin ich
endlich auf die Idee gekommen. Aber es ist mir auch
nicht erklärbar, wie kann
so eine dünne Haut feuerresistent
sein. Ja, das ist die Frage.
Warum ist nicht einfach alles feuerresistent?
Warum machen wir vorher nicht ein für
allemal den Gar aus und sagen, jetzt reicht's aber auch mal. Jede Kleidung, jedes Haargel, alles feuerresistent. Jede Hautcreme, feuerresistent. Ist nicht alles, was nicht feuerresistent ist, eine Einladung, dafür in Flammen aufzugehen? Eigentlich sollte man nicht feuerresistent draufschreiben, sondern höchst flammbar. Ja, genau. Auf alles. Surprisingly flammbar. Ja, super, super flammbar. So aufpassen, dass man es nicht zu euphorisch sagt. Jetzt will ich diesen Film sehen. Was macht Sandra Bullock dann da oben, um die herannahende Tragödie zu verändern? Ja, erst mal sagt jemand, lass uns den Ballon kaputt machen. Und dann? Ja, dann wie? Und dann habt ihr mal einen Schlüssel. Ich werfe einen Schlüssel auf den Ballon und versuche ein Loch dadurch reinzureißen. Sandra, das würde ein zu grosses Loch, sie heißt auch Sandra, die Figur, das würde ein zu grosses Loch in die Hülle schießen. Dann würden wir zu schnell fallen. Ja, aber wir steigen pro Minute höher. Es wird immer schlimmer. Okay. Bis uns die Luft ausgeht.
Ich kletter hoch und dann steckt er irgendwann oben im Heliumballon und ruft runter mit Todesangst. Nein, ich krieg kein Loch in die Auswand, nein! Und hat diese qualvoll unten ist das Kind, weil der Vater ist hochgestiegen und unten ist das Kind. Und der Vater stirbt oben in den Heliumballon. Sagt meiner Mutter, dass ich sie liebe! Ich krieg keine Luft mehr! Skino weint. Aber er muss den Opfer bringen, um oben in den Heliumballon zu steigen. Sanderock ist like, what the fuck? Warum mache ich hier mit? Da muss man eine Agentur wechseln. Aber der Film ist traurig. Es ist schwierig, aber ich glaube, es ist eine gute Situation. Und vor allem dann kommen auch so andere Figuren, weil dann hast du ja nämlich zum den Bogenschützen am Boden, der Hobby-Bogenschütze.
Legolas.
Legolas, Orlando Bloom brauchen auch mal wieder eine Rolle.
Stimmt.
Und macht gerade Cosplay oder so, Legolas Cosplay, da kann man so einen selbstreferentiellen Gag machen, dass Orlando Bloom als Legolas Cosplay macht auf der Comic-Con in Berlin.
Ja, super.
Er spielt nicht Orlando Bloom, er spielt Bolendo Loom und dann sieht er plötzlich, oh mein Gott, der steigt auf und dann schiesst er mit seinem Bogen, versucht er Löcher reinzuschliessen in Heliomballon, trifft aber das vierjährige Mädchen Cleopatra, die dann als Ballast über Bord geworfen wird. Was, Samuel Bullock das Leben rettet? Ne, weil sie denken, Moment mal, dann steigen wir noch schneller. Ach ja, stimmt. Ah, stimmt. Ganz kurz. Sorry. Ich opfer mich, ich springe. Na, hä? Dem Kind wurde vorher von den Wissenschaftlern nicht gut erklärt, wie Physik funktioniert, wie Schwerkraft. Warum hast du dem nicht zugehört, Schatz? Du hast den Nobelpreis recht. Einschlag in Berlin. Ja, es könnte passieren. Ich glaube, es ist eine tolle Geschichte, weil du natürlich
auch viele Ebenen hast. Du hast natürlich einmal
die Sandra Bullock-Ebene, die recht schnell
langweilig wird, du sagst, ja,
wir steigen so hoch, wie es geht, und dann können wir halt kaum
noch atmen, aber
oder wir können ja an dem
Drahtseil runterklettern.
Nee, das ist ja gerissen. Ja, aber das hängt ja trotzdem
noch dreißig. Du fällst etwas weniger.
Ja, du hast doch noch dreißig Meter. Mhm. Es ist die Frage, es ist wirklich gerissen. Ja, aber das hängt ja trotzdem noch dreißig. Du fällst etwas weniger. Ja, du hast doch 30 Meter. Mhm. Es ist die Frage, es ist wirklich eine Frage. Also ich glaube, ein Loch in die Außenwand machen ist das Beste, was dir passieren kann. Ja, mach mal ein Loch in so eine Hüpfburg mit blossen Händen. Dann kommt so eine Kill Bill Ebene, wie die dann diese Faust in einem Sarg Ebene hat, weißt du? Dann kommt so eine Kill Bill Ebene, ich muss von im Inneren des Sargs ein Loch in die Sargwand. Du würdest es mit diesem Three-Inch-Punch versuchen. Der Three-Inch-Punch, den du lernst, dass der ganze zweite Akt ist, wie sie das lernt, ehe dann magically Lou Bloom unten auftaucht. Lou Bloom von Nightcrawler. Nein, Orlando Bloom. Dein Bloom, Orlando Bloom. Orlando Bloom, sorry. Ja, aber wobei, jetzt wo ich sage, Lou Bloom kann ja auch da sein, weil er ist ja erst am Tatort. Der filmt das ganze. Der filmt das ganze. Es ist Nightcrawler 2. Es ist Found-Futage von Lou Bloom. Aber diese ganze zweite Akte, diese Kill Bill-Sequenz, wie der Vater im Inneren des Ballons, während er sich die Luft anhält, verlernen muss, diesen Three-Inch-Punch zu machen. Du hast da noch so ein Teenager-Mädchen darauf, die ganz lange Fingernägel hat, wo es heißt, mach du das, du hast die längsten Fingernägel gemacht. Nein. Nein. Genau, die sich nicht die Fingerdreggel machen will. Ja, genau. Die am Ende für alle runterspringt. Und am Ende dann, ich nehme deine Hand. Ich brauche deine Hand. Ja, okay. Kletter mit mir hoch und dann mit der Hand der Teenagerin sticht Sandra Bullock in den Ballon. Und dann tritt das Helium aus. Helium tritt aus. Alle freuen sich. Alle freuen sich, reden wieder ein bisschen tiefer und landen sanft in einer Spree. Ja, genau. Mega, finde ich super gut. Er ist ein toller Film. Also wie gesagt, ich verstehe es immer noch nicht, warum unsere Filme nicht umgesetzt werden. Es scheint fast so, als hätten wir kein Draht zu Hollywood, dass da nicht einer mal sagt so, ja, schreib da mal mit, bitte. Wir haben kein Draht zu Hollywood und kein Draht zum deutschen Hollywood, Dollywood. Guido Kanz macht jetzt irgendwie wieder eine Show, die schon 30 Milliarden Jahre lief, dann nicht mehr und jetzt macht er die wieder. Tele5 ist taub. Tele5 ist völlig taub. Taub. Nichts. Kommt nichts zurück. Gar nichts. Überhaupt nichts. Und ich verstehe auch nicht, das haben uns viele geschrieben, dass sie nicht verstehen können, dass Guido Kanz keine unserer unserer Ideen überhaupt in Erwägung zieht. Und nochmal Insider-Informationen, es sind nicht immer Gespräche stattgefunden. Niemand ist an uns herangetreten. Nee, wir sind eher von uns weggetreten, als wir herangetreten sind. Und so ein paar, so wie so ein Tanz ist man voneinander her geflohen. Aber man muss sagen, das ist nämlich das deutsche Fernsehen, ich sehe ein bisschen schwarz. Es gibt ja sowas wie Initiativbewerbungen, dass Leute sich, ohne dass es jemand will, sich bewirbt. Wir haben Initiativablehnungen bekommen. Also Sender haben unsere Formate abgelehnt, bevor wir sie ihnen gepitcht haben. Jetzt warte doch mal, jetzt warte doch mal. Nein, nein, nein. Das ist ganz unüblich in der Branche, dass Firmen auf eineninzugehen und sagen, wir werden auf gar keinen Fall eure Idee umsetzen.
Ja.
Es wird nicht passieren. Wird Punkt nicht Punkt passieren Punkt.
Wieso klatscht die Hose dazwischen? Wird nicht passieren.
Ja, von daher die Nachricht ist angekommen, aber vielleicht werdet ihr euch wundern und rotieren, wenn wir es erfolgreich umsetzen und den deutschen Fernsehpreis damit gewinnen und in die Höhe ragen, strecken, wenn wir ihn gewonnen haben. Wir werden den deutschen Fernsehpreis in die Höhe strecken. Machen Leute auch selten sich mal so richtig über den Preis freundlich. Yes, Alter, yes, ich hab den Oscar. Yes, in your face, in your face, Jennifer Lawrence, in your face, Meryl Streep, yes. Aber es ist auch,, ich finde, das finde ich sehr sympathisch, aber wenn du so über einen deutschen Fernsehpreis dich freust, das finde ich dann wiederum ein bisschen merkwürdig. Yes! What? Yes! Da ist er! Da ist das Ding! Publikum klatscht schon seit fünf Minuten nicht mehr, weil alle wollen ans Buffet. Du ziehst dein Jackett aus, ziehst dein Trikot aus, jubelst, wirbelst es rum, freust dich richtig, machst diesen Auf-Knien-Rutscher, wenn du irgendwie die Trophäen entgegennimmst. Der nie funktioniert, weil nicht so rutschig, wie man denkt. Die Welt ist nicht so rutschig, wie man denkt. Überhaupt nicht. Und man rennt auch nicht so schnell wie Profisportler. Also man denkt immer, man kann das auch, aber nein, die rennen einfach viermal so schnell wie du. Ja.
Was wollte ich immer machen mit der Band, wollte ich immer so hochspringen wie die Profimusiker von Green Day auf den Konzerten, wenn die immer so hochspringen und die Beine so hochreissen, die Gitarre auf den letzten Akkord und so. Habe ich mal gemacht auf der Bühne, habe ich mal ein Video gesehen und es sieht nicht so spezakulär bei mir aus, weil ich viele Essentials vergessen habe, zum Beispiel, dass man die Beine anzieht, dass es höher aussieht. So was, Kleinigkeiten. Ich bin einfach gesprungen und wieder diese 20 cm sahen jetzt sehr unspektakulär aus eher. Es war so ein Soft Rock. Du bist ja an sich schon sehr gross, das heißt, auch in Relationen wirkt die Höhe nicht so beeindruckend. War auch nicht hilfreich, dass die Höhe nicht beeindruckend war. Ja, das war nicht so gut. Aber da muss man sich mal hinter die Fahne schreiben. Die machen ja jahrzehntelanges Sprungtraining, Green Day, damit die wirklich da eine respektable Höhe erreichen. Man denkt ja als Amateur immer so, ja das sind normale Leute körperlich, nein, das sind auf dem Niveau von Profiathleten. Genau, zumindest was die Sprungfähigkeit angeht. Bei mir sah das nicht so gut aus, aber da muss man drauf achten, wenn man sich freut über den Bambi, wenn man sich dann so richtig ausrastet. Vor allem, wenn man es das vierte Mal gewinnt in Folge. Adele einfach wieder alle Grammys und dann beim vierten Mal so richtig freuen. Welchen deutschen Preis willst du auf jeden Fall mal gewinnen? So richtig. Henry Nunnen. Henry Nunnen Journalistenpreis. Ja, das ist einfach meiner. Und was machst du dafür? Ich habe einfach schon vor langer Zeit einfach meinen Visier auf diesen Henry Nunnenpreis gerichtet. Und eines Tages will ich ihn in mein Regal spielen. Hängt da auch an deinem Kühlschrank, hängt so ein Magnet, so ein Bild du so rein gephotoshoppt bist mit dem Henry-Nan-Preis, weil das dein Traum ist. Ja, jeden Morgen, wenn ich Workout mache, wenn ich Recherche-Workout mache, wenn ich einfach Dinge als Übung recherchiere, dann kommt immer so die Rocky-Musik dazu und ich habe einfach meinen Blick auf diesen Preis, Henry-Nan-Preis. Was hast du heute recherchiert als Übung? Der Eichen-Ära, Ära. Jetzt habe ich vergessen, wer heißt. Okay, also weil nicht so, du bist noch am Anfang, du übst ja noch, du hast nicht so gut recherchiert. Der Eichenhäher, das ist der Gärtner des Waldes. Eichelherr. Ja, stimmt, Eichelherr, Herr, äh, ich weiß nicht, wie man es ausspricht, genau. Ich weiß nicht, wie man es schreibt, Eichelherr. Das ist der Gärtner des Waldes, weil der vergräbt die ganzen Nüsse und vergisst die dann. Ist der Gärtner des Waldes oder der Förster des Gartens? Der Förster des Gartens. Weil Gärtner des Waldes klingt ein bisschen unterqualifiziert, ehrlich gesagt. Findest du nicht? Ja, ein bisschen. Aber ich glaube, es ist eine gute Beschreibung, weil der pflanzt neue Sachen an. Und der versteckt die ganzen Nüsse im Boden und vergisst die dann.
Ja, das machen die Eichhörnchen. Eichhörnchen machen alle, machen alle.
Aber es gibt wesentlich mehr Eichhörnchen als Eichhörnchen und deswegen sind die viel wichtiger.
Und da kann man tatsächlich im Wald, wenn man Lust hat, die auf einer erhöhten Position, damit sie die Rehe nicht fressen, ein paar Eichhörn hinlegen und dann verteilt er die.
So kann man, wenn man Lust hat, Bäume zu pflanzen, kann man das einfach den Vogel übernehmen lassen, weil der kann das besser als der Dusselmensch, der da durchs Unterholz läuft und die ganzen kleinen Bäume kaputt tritt, kann der Vogel das besser. Also falls ihr Bäume pflanzen wollt, macht das über den Eichel her. Das habe ich heute recherchiert, weil ich dachte, Henry Nunn, du sitzt da irgendwo da draußen, irgendwo da draußen sitzt du mit deinem Cognac-Glas. Und dann hast du dich irgendwann zurückgelehnt, so selig, und hast so einen Preis geguckt und gedacht. Ja. Du hast genickt und gelächelt und gesagt, eines Tages. Ja, eines Tages krieg ich dich. Und, okay, du arbeitest wirklich daraufhin aktiv. Initiativ, ja. Ich recherchiere initiativ, ich habe kein Projekt dazu. Ich versuche einfach initiativ zu recherchieren, was mir vor die Flinte kommt. So machen da Journalisten, man braucht ja auch ein ausgeprägtes Gespür für Stories, und deswegen bin ich da immer auf der Suche. So, wer nur tagesaktuell arbeitet, der hängt dem Zeitgeist hinterher. Nur wer wirklich weiterblicken kann, der ist der eigentlich Schnelle. Okay, spannend. Man sagt ja, es gibt nichts Ältere als die Zeitung von gestern. Und du treibst auf die Spitze und sagst, es gibt nichts Ältere als die Zeitung von heute. Genau. Okay. Guck mal, ich bin da einfach an der Front. Ich streite da voran. Und wenn ich dafür keinen Henry-Gran-Preis verdient habe, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Also vielleicht, falls ihr ihn kennt, heim HNP, wie wir sagen. Falls er irgendwie euer Nachbar ist oder so, könnt ihr mal beim Müll rausbringen und sagen, Mensch, was ich wieder gehört habe, den Eichelherr. Herr Nann, haben Sie das gehört, was Herr Well recherchiert hat über den Eichelherr? Herr? Ist das nicht unglaublich? Herr? Ja, weil das Ä mit drin ist, das hat mich verwirrt. Warum gibt es keine vernünftige Datenbank zur Aussprache? Das zum Beispiel, Achtung, App-Idee. Wir leben in einer globalisierten Welt, wir haben viel mit Menschen zu tun, die keinen klassisch deutschen Namen haben, wo man oft das Problem hat, wie spricht man denn aus? Bei vielen Namen weiss ich einfach nicht, wie man ausspricht. Und was man dann macht, ist, man vermeidet es dann den Namen zu benutzen, was auch blöd ist, man würde gerne die Person direkt ansprechen.
Deswegen, warum nicht einfach eine fucking Datenbank mit allen Vornamen der Welt, das sind ja auch nicht unendlich viele, und einfach, wie man die ausspricht. Und dann kann man die Person direkt mit der richtigen Aussprache ansprechen, anstatt immer dieses dumme, äh, sage ich es jetzt richtig, korrigiere mich, wenn ich es jetzt falle, dieses Bullshit, worauf keiner mehr Bock hat, worauf die Leute am wenigsten Bock haben, die Namen haben, die jetzt vielleicht deutschsprachig nicht so ganz geläufig ist, einfach eine Website, wie spricht man es aus, kann jeder seinen eigenen Namen einsprechen, zack. Wie spricht man es Punkt aus? So, australische Domain, wie spricht man es aus? Finde ich gut. Und dann legen wir da alle Namen an, die es gibt auf der Welt, mit einem, und du sprichst dann alle einmal ein, wie man es ausspricht. Gerne, ich würde das gerne übernehmen. Mit einem kleinen Playbutton, so. Aber jetzt ist schon meine Frage, wenn jemand sagt, ich heiss Patrick oder Patrick, also jemand schreibt dir, ich heiss P-A-T und dann buchstabiert. P-A-T-R-L. Genau, das kann dann Michael übernehmen. So, und dann, ich stolpere nämlich immer, wenn ich, als ich mit unseren Kollegen, unserem gemeinsamen Co-Autoren vom Neomagazin gesprochen habe, Patrick, heisst der ist nämlich Patrick, wieder geschrieben wie Patrick, und ich habe manchmal gesagt, Patrick, Patrick, äh, fuck, und dann ärgert man sich selber sich selbst und den ganzen Tag ist ruiniert, weil man sich versprochen hat.
Das willst du ja auch vermeiden damit.
Aber wie willst du das vermeiden?
Dann musst du einfach wissen, wie er genannt wurde. Die Eltern wissen das ja nur. Ja, oder wenn du eine Mail schreibst, dann schreibst du mit Liebegrüsse Patrick und der Name ist ein Link auf wie spricht man's punkt aus, wo die richtige Aussprache dargestellt wird, wo er selber eingesprochen hat Patrick.
Sehr viel lautstecken Hintergrund, Bahn fährt vorbei, im Hintergrund hört man, nein, das kannst du nicht, das kannst du hier nicht machen. Und man fragt sich, hat er keine Zeit gehabt, das woanders zu machen? Du lernst gleich viel über die Person, weißt direkt, in welchem Umfeld sie wohnt. Ich möchte das meine, ich habe nämlich keine Anrufbeantworter Sachen. Hi, ist der Stefan, wenn du eine Nachricht für mich hast. Einfach nach dem Ton. Bis dann habe ich nicht. Stattdessen, aber wenn ich es machen würde, und das beobachte ich manchmal, bei Leuten, die das an sehr lauten Orten machen, wo dann im Hintergrund noch eine Bahn durchfährt und Applaus oder so. Man denkt, wo sind die da? Meeresrauschen, Nebelhorn oder Nebelhorn. Und man fragt sich, hast du keine zwei Minuten zu Hause gefunden, wo du das kurz mal in Ruhe aufnimmst? Aber ich finde es auch ganz geil, weil es einfach direkt aussagt, ich habe zu tun, ich habe keine Zeit dafür. Mach es trotzdem, weil es sich gebietet, finde ich super. Das ist, glaube ich, auch so der Unterschied zwischen introvertiert und extrovertiert. Ich glaube, introvertierte Leute machen a, hundert Takes oder gar nicht und können irgendwann Hallo nicht mehr richtig aussprechen, weil hi, hi, hi, hi, hey, hi und extvertierte einfach ... Nicht bei jeder Sprachnachricht.
Extrovertierte einfach, während sie auf dem Motorrad sitzen nebenbei.
Hey, übrigens, ich bin Ulrich, ich lasse die Nachricht da.
Ciao.
Ja, aloha, was geht denn?
Völlig aloha, was geht einfach.
Und einfach ansonsten wie immer, hi, hey, hi, hey, hey.
Irgendwann beherrscht man die eigene Sprache nicht mehr.
Nein, man weiss nicht mehr, wie man ...
Hi, du, ich wollte nur sagen ... Viel zu hoch, man wird auch immer höher. Hi, hier ist der Stefan, ich wollte nur mal sagen, dass ich nicht mehr ... Ich, ähm, 015 ... Und man merkt, ich habe viel zu hoch angefangen, ich muss die Höhe jetzt halten. Hi Leute, ich wollte nur sagen, dass ich, ähm, dass ich dann auch wiederkomme und bis dann, ciao. Furchtbar, furchtbar. Ja, aber ich glaube, es wäre eine wichtige Website, weil ich habe oft das Problem, dass, also man will auch nicht immer sagen, die Verantwortung den Leuten übergeben, so sag einfach mal, stell dich mal vor. Und die nervt das wahrscheinlich so, ich kenne es ja auch irgendwie, wenn man ständig den Namen falsch sagt und irgendwie und dann dieses ewige Hin und Her, so, so, so, so. Also deswegen einfach nachgucken, wie man die andere Person ausspricht.
Ich finde das Projekt schön, aber ich finde sehr viel Aufwand für ein Problem, was ich jetzt nicht so habe im Alltag, dass man Namen falsch ausspricht.
Ja.
Weil es ist eine Arroganz, dass du den Namen nicht merkst?
Nee, ich habe ihn noch nie gehört.
Dein Narzissmus?
Man hat so ein Meeting, man kriegt eine E-Mail von jemandem mit einem Namen, wo man nicht sofort weiss, wie man ausspricht, und dann weiss man, ah, Zoom-Meeting um elf. Und du, okay, das wird jetzt ein Hey, Meister, was geht? Das wird so eine Art von Gespräch. Wobei das finde ich das Beste an diesen Zoom-Meetings, finde ich, dass die Namen immer unter den Leuten stehen. Ja, das ist super. Das finde ich das Beste. Das ist richtig gut. Weil ich weiss oft Namen nicht und dann stehen die mal da drunter. Und das Problem waren neulich einmal zwei Leute im Call, die aber beieinander saßen und dann stand nur der Name von der einen Person. Ich wusste nie, wer von beiden das jetzt ist. Ja, das ist auch gut. Das war dann ein bisschen schwierig, aber normalerweise steht der Name drunter, das finde ich ganz toll. Ja, aber dann steht da halt Jesus und du weißt nicht, ist es Jesus, Jesus, wie
spricht man die Person an und dann sagt man
hey, Kollege, was
steht da? Maestro.
Du, ich wollte nochmal zurückkommen auf die Idee von
dem Herrn vor dem grünen Bild
und also
ich glaube, das würde vielen Leuten helfen, aber ja,
wie alle unsere Ideen, Names, Names, Names,
Names, Krebs auch vor sich hin, interessiert niemanden. Wir haben zwei Mails bekommen für Namen, für Bands, die sich Leute noch sichern können.
Names, names, names, names, names.com war die Seite, wo man für Projekte aller Art Datenbanken... Namen vorschlagen kann, ja genau. Angenommen, ich habe eine tolle Idee für einen Firmennamen, ich will aber keine Firma gründen.
Da also kann ich den Namen auf names, names, names, names.com posten, sodass jemand, der das andere Problem hat, ich habe eine tolle Idee für eine Firma, aber mir fällt einfach kein Name ein. Ich habe einen Namen für eine Band. The Audacity. The Audacity. Finde ich gut. Finde ich einen guten Bandnamen. Ja. Weil es klingt so wie ein Bandname, aber es hat so viele Ebenen, das könnte ja immer allein, also ich will jetzt als der Erfinder dieses Namens will ich jetzt nicht alle Ebenen für euch aufdröseln. Das muss im ersten Konzeptalbum. Das Kunstwerk soll für sich stehen, aber The Audacity ... Eigentlich will ich ... Es gibt eine Band, die heisst Audacity. Audacity is an American Garage Rock Band from Fullerton, California, United States. Okay, okay. Members Matt Schmalfeld, Kyle Gibson ... Matt, listen, Matt, listen. Add the the. Matt. But we already removed the the. Add the the. Ciao. That was that's that that was it for me. My name is Sean Parker. I invented the Napster. And I made a huge mistake, removing the the. So I try to make it up by adding the the wherever I can. McDonald's, the McDonald's. Da muss man aber echt aufpassen bei Bands, weil manche Bands haben the und manche nicht. The Beatles, aber Rolling Stones. Und man darf das nicht verwechseln, man darf nicht sagen The Rolling Stones oder Beatles. The Beatles. Du musst immer gucken, The Ramones, aber The Nine Inch Nails, das geht nicht. Du musst genau wissen, wo ist The The, wo nicht. Auch die Frage, ob man das dann eindeutschen darf, Die Beatles. Nein, das geht nicht. Die The Beatles. Die Who. Der Who? Na, die Who. Nee, du musst Die The Beatles sagen. Die the Beatles. Die the Beatles, genau wie du die die Ärzte sagst. Du musst schon einfach die Artikel, Respekt der Artikel. Respekt the article. Das muss schon das Mindeste sein. Wenn du Fan bist, ansonsten nicht. Ja, finde ich haben sie liegen lassen. The Audacity wäre der coolere Bandname gewesen. Macht's aber jetzt kaputt, weil ich mich nicht wie Audacity nennen.
Doch, klar.
Weil die haben schon Textbildner wahrscheinlich gesichert.
At the the.
Kannst du nicht einfach the.aus dir die Website holen?
The.audacity.
Mal gucken, ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich schau mal, wie teuer eine australische Website ist.
Ob man da wirklich noch ... Gibt's wirklich Punkt aus?
Wie spricht man das Punkt aus?
Wikipedia-Punkt aus.
Nee, das gibt's, glaube ich, nicht.
Aus Army of the United States.
Australien, Kfz-Kennzeichen.
Das Kfz-Kennzeichen von Australien ist AUS.
Arbeiten unter Spannung.
Oder es gibt auch eine Ortschaft in Namibia, die heißt Aus. Und da kommen wir auch schon zu unserem Top-Thema. Denn wir alle lieben den Kontinent Afrika, der kein Land ist. Ach so. Nein, nein, nein. Der Kontinent Afrika ist ein Kontinent, der besteht aus, ja, wie vielen Ländern? Fünfzig Länder. Das ist die Frage. Wir haben ja uns in Antenne Afrika schon einige angeschaut, aber jetzt kann es gut sein, dass alles Gelernte in den geistigen Mülleimer wandern muss, denn es tut sich was in Afrika. Jetzt kommt der Jingle, das ist der Ort, wo der Jingle kommt. Nee, das ist der andere, wir brauchen anderen Jingle. Nee, ist doch Antenne Afrika. Nee, es ist nicht Antenne Afrika, es ist Antenne der Fakt, wir haben Fehler gemacht, Afrika. Aber Antenne Afrika heißt ja jetzt nicht, dass wir Beiträge von Hörern, Hörerinnen zeigen, sondern ja auch, wir reden grob über den Kontinent Afrika. Boah, das weiß ich nicht. Nein? Wie die das in der Puffepedia dann hat. Je nachdem, wie diese dreiständige Diskussion ausgehen wird, kommt jetzt entweder das Intro oder nicht. Viel Spaß mit. Ja, jedenfalls. Wir reden lieber Afrika, Afrika. Ich habe nämlich auch gelesen, dass sich da was tut auf dem Kontinent, über den wir so wenig wissen. Nämlich habe ich gehört, dass einige Länder sich zusammenschliessen wollen. Genau, einige afrikanische Länder wollen sich zusammenrotten, um ein grösseres Land zu gestalten.
Und ja, das ist natürlich ein Problem für uns, weil natürlich dann diese alten Landesgrenzen,
an die wir uns gewöhnt haben, die wir auswendig gelernt haben, wir können sie alle nochmal aufzählen, wenn ihr das wollt.
Aber ich glaube, wir können uns sparen.
Und das ist natürlich ein Problem, denn einige Länder wollen sich zusammenschliessen. Stefan, welche? So genau habe ich jetzt ... Also anders als du bin ich nicht am Hendrenanpreis interessiert und habe die Recherche früher abgebrochen. Das war ja die Rubrik, die du vorbereiten solltest für diese Folge. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Nation. Ähm, Nationen, wie googelt man das jetzt am besten? Du hast Recherche-Seminar belegt. Genau. Nationen Afrikas zusammen schliessen. Die Netzwerk Afrika-Deutschland. So, vertiefte Partnerschaft mit Afrika im Fokus. Bericht Ausbreitung des Kolonialismus. Drucksache 19,8, 7, 6, 5. Länder verbinden. Ja, das habe ich gerade schon. Verbinden hast du? Nee, zusammenschliessen. Zusammenschliessen, ja. Afrika. Ja, weil es gibt schon länger die Idee, die Union afrikanischer Staaten, dass man sich da zusammenschliess. Ähm, das gab es auch mal als kurzzeitiges Projekt in den 60er Jahren zwischen Ghana, Guinea und Mali. Aber wie das ausgegangen ist. Wissen wir ja.
Entweder wissen wir es oder wir wollen es nicht spoilern.
Aber ja, das ist, also entweder
haben wir das geträumt.
Naja, wenn ihr uns unterstützen
wollt für dieses Projekt,
dann schaut doch mal
patreon.com
das Podcast-UFO
nur so auf der sicheren Seite, dass dieser premium content ja weiterhin zu euch nach hause genau und also ich bin auf google seite vier und wenn es da nicht steht dann existiert es nicht würde ich sagen ich bin in der das podcast ufo reddit subreddit seite das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Wie heißt das nochmal? Reddit.com slash r slash das Podcast UFO. Jetzt ist es Michael, der euch das bittet. Jetzt muss er aus dem Intro, muss ich es nochmal zurück. Fuck, ey, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Doch, doch. Interessiert sich denn niemand für Afrika oder was? Ich finde gar nichts. Leute, da entsteht ein neues Land. Wann ist das letzte neue Land entstanden? Das ist auch eine gute Frage. Ich kriege nur mit, dass man auch in Europa natürlich gibt es Versuche, die Vereinigten Staaten von Europa daraus zu machen. Ja, also auf jeden Fall, wir tragen das nach, welche Länder das sind. Und ja, es ist natürlich für uns jetzt ein Problem, deswegen würde ich sagen, wir sind da eher dagegen, oder?
Ich möchte mich dazu noch nicht positionieren. Also dann haben wir einmal eine Enthaltung und einmal eine Nein-Stimme aus dem Podcast-UFO-Bereich.
Und weil ich habe jetzt alle Länder Afrikas gelernt, wenn die jetzt anfangen, sich zusammenzuschliessen, dann ist das Quatsch. Vor allem, glaube ich, waren das Länder, die gar nicht alle notwendigerweise geografisch verbunden sind. Das heißt, es gibt dann wieder so einen Fleckenteppich. So einen Fleckenteppich. Ja, wo dann manche hier zusammen verbunden sind und manche nicht. Aber die machen das natürlich absichtlich, dass sie einmal Uganda umschliessen und dann zu sagen, ja, du gehörst nicht zu uns, aber alle um dich herum schon.
Und dann natürlich geopolitisch, wir alle wissen, wie das läuft. Ich glaube, jeder weiß tief drin, wie das am Ende ablaut. Leben wir gerade in einer Zeit, wo die Landesgrenzen so lange erhalten sind, jetzt habe ich es auch bei dem Ukraine-Konflikt gedacht, wo Russland ja rein will, um ihr Gebiet zu erweitern, wo ich mich jetzt gefragt habe, leben wir in einer Zeit, wo die Landesgrenzen so lange jetzt schon beständig waren, wie noch lange nicht, wie zuvor noch nie, so? Also, leben wir gerade in der Zeit, in der die Landesgrenzen am beständigsten waren in der Geschichte.
Das weiss ich nicht. Weil ich glaube, es ist im Mittelalter mal so zwischen 1300 und 1400 mal so 100 Jahre, wo einfach gar nichts passiert ist, weil alle damit zu kämpfen hatten, nicht zu sterben. Weil die, ja okay. Aber was ich mich frage, was ist die geringste Anzahl an Ländern, die man braucht auf der Welt? Also angenommen, alle schließen sich zu einem Land zusammen. Ist das dann besser oder schlechter? Oder sagt man, nee, man braucht mindestens drei Länder auf der Welt?
Also wenn jetzt hier die Afrikanische Union sich da mit der EU zusammenschliesst, das ist ein grosses Land, und dann hast du einmal Asienland und Amerikaland und alles einfach zusammen, drei Länder auf der Welt, drei Währungen, drei Nationalhymnen, drei Fussballteams. Ich meine, sportlich gesehen ein bisschen langweilig. Boring as fuck, ja. Sag's ruhig, wie es ist. Aber du hast natürlich dann sehr gute Spieler in den Teams. Also wenn du wirklich alle amerikanischen und südamerikanischen Spieler in einem Team steckst, Boah, Alter, stell dir vor, Brasilien und Argentinien, Alter, Messi und ja, erstmal meine Frage, brauchen wir noch Städte? Braucht man noch Städte? Warum sind Städte, das ist meine Frage für die Folge, wir können immer mitnehmen, so nur mal nachdenken. Aber warum machen wir Städte nicht zu Ländern? Also wir machen Städte so gross, dass sie zu Ländern werden. Warum gibt es überhaupt noch Städte? Ah, du sagst in die andere Richtung, eher mehr Länder. Nee, nee, nee, weniger Länder, finde ich gut. Größere Städte? Aber dann lass auch die Städte wegmachen. Warum noch diese Mini-Ausbittung in den Ländern? Warum gibt es noch diese Mini-Ausbittungen? Warum denken wir noch in Städten? Warum denken wir so lokal patriotisch? Warum denken wir nicht eher als grosses Ganzes? Ja, wenn du die Städte zu Ländern machst, dann kriegst du doch noch mehr. Köln soll ein eigenes Land sein. Nein, Köln ja, meinetwegen, aber es ist halt alles Deutschland. Köln wird ab jetzt zu Deutschland und das wird ja zu Europa, heisst Europa, Köln ist Europa, Paris ist Europa. Alles, warum brauchst du noch Städte? Ausser für Namen, aber politisch, warum brauchst du oder Fussballmannschaft? Aber wenn Köln doch eh schon Teil von Deutschland ist, was willst du dann ändern? Länder, Städte sollen weg. Wie Städte sollen weg? Was soll das bedeuten? Städte haben keine Bedeutung mehr. Städte, weil es grenzt ab. Stadtmauern grenzen ab, reist Mauern nieder. Stadtmauern niederreißen, das ist dein Programm. Auch wie Bundesliga. Dein politisches Programm ist Städte, Mauern niederreißen. Bundesliga zirnt nur Feindschaften zwischen verfeindeten Städten. Ja, aber wenn es nur ein Team gibt, dann können die gegen niemanden spielen. Doch, doch, jetzt kommt dann dein Programm, wir koalieren nämlich, und dein Programm kommt ja zum Tragen, dass es nur noch drei Länder gibt. Ja. Genau, die spielen dann gegeneinander. Also die Weltmeisterschaft, drei Teams, eins kriegt Auto-Win, oder man hat eine Gruppenphase, jeder spielt einmal gegen jeden, und dann fliegt der Schlechteste raus, und beiden sind im Finale. Ja, geht. Da hast du das in einem Wochenende durch. Und dann ist nicht mehr Schalke, Dortmund, Bremen, Hamburg, nee, das ist alles Amerika. Ja, denkt mal drüber nach, Leute, nehmt das mal mit in die Woche und lasst das mal sacken, bitte. Und wir werden auf jeden Fall nachreichen, was in Afrika los ist. Vielleicht, falls ihr euch mit Afrika gut auskennt und vor allem mit diesem Zusammenschluss der Länder gut auskennt, wer sagt denn, dass Antenne Afrika nur Länderbeschreibungen sein können? Niemand ist die Antwort. Niemand hat das festgelegt und ihr könnt auch hier Konventionen aufbrechen. Überhaupt gibt es sehr wenig Stimmen zu der Rubrik, muss man auch mal sagen. Also nicht nur hat niemand festgelegt, was das ist, noch gibt es auch irgendeine Form von Reaktion. Der Aufschrei, wenn wir das Format abändern würden, wäre, glaube ich, mäuserig klein. Ja, aber das ist genau das Problem, weil eben nicht, weil alle keinen Einstieg haben.
Und das Ding ist, ich scrolle bis jetzt, seitdem ich gerade recherchiert habe, bis jetzt scrolle ich durch die, durch unser Reddit und habe oben als Steuerung F Suche Afrika drin.
Niemanden interessiert an Afrika.
Und da muss man aufhören, Leute, wir müssen uns noch ein bisschen mehr mit auseinanderhalten.
Ja, ihr müsst wirklich, hört mal auf, ständig irgendwie Sachen anzugucken oder so, sondern beschäftigt euch mit Afrika. Es ist ein riesiger Kontinent. Riesengross. Er ist sogar noch grösser, als man denkt, weil unsere Karten sind westzentristisch. Weißt du das? Ja. Ja? Okay. Deswegen arbeite ich ja nur mit Globen.
Das ist ja meine Methode.
Deswegen ist deine Wohnung voller Globen.
Und noch deine Stadt Köln-Karte, die du ja, wenn es nach mir geht, gar nicht mehr brauchst.
Ich brauch sie noch.
Hast du aber auch auf einem ... Auch gewölbt, ja.
Aber nicht so doll.
Auch gewölbt.
Nee, nee, ist kaum gewölbt.
Aber man merkt es doch ein bisschen.
Man merkt es schon ein bisschen.
Ja, ja.
Es ist, wenn man sie auf den Tisch legt, dann wackelt sie immer so links und rechts. Leicht. Man merkt, die ist nicht ganz gerade. Warum? Naja, weil ich halt die Erdkrümmung mit eingerechnet habe. Und du weißt ganz genau, du kannst den Dom irgendwann nicht mehr sehen. Wohingegen bei mir auf meinen Karten ist Ehrenfeld immer zu klein und die Südstadt immer zu groß. Ja. Ne, weil es eine südstadtzentristische Köln-Karte ist. Das sind natürlich jetzt Themen, die man mal explizit ansprechen muss. Nee, ich weiß, das spricht man ungern an, aber wir sprechen immer die Themen, um die es wirklich geht, die wirklich wichtig sind. Zurück zu dem Heißluftballon-Ding. Ja, zurück zum Heißluftballon. Je höher der steigt, desto mehr Länder können ihn sehen. Und irgendwann kann ihn sogar die halbe Welt sehen, wenn er hoch genug steigt ist. Irgendwann kann man ihn sogar auf dem Weltall sehen. Ja. Ist er so nah am Weltall, dass man ihn aus dem Weltall sehen kann. Das stimmt. Vielleicht sagt dann irgendwann die ISS, ja, wir fangen ihn auf. Er drückt uns auch mit raus. Was ich mich frage, Heliumballon, extrem unglücklich, dotzt leider genau an die ISS und drückt die auch weiter aus der Umlaufbeschreibung. Unglücklich. Und Bullock so, sorry, sorry, oh fuck, sorry, wir dachten, wir können bei euch andocken, sorry, und die, nein, nein, nein, nein. Und so wird plötzlich Nightcrawler 2 zu Gravity 2. Aber da steht eigentlich drei Formate, also einmal Herr der Ringe vier, Nightcrawler zwei, Gravity zwei. Ja, da stehen eigentlich drei Formate,
also einmal Herr der Ringe vier,
Nightcrawler zwei, Gravity
zwei, es ist alles ein Film.
Es ist ein bisschen Speed, es ist ein bisschen
Sandra Bullock Speed, aber es ist sehr
ja genau, es ist auch ein bisschen, Kennery ist auch mit auf dem
aber den lässt das alles sehr kalt.
Der hat auch gar nichts auf diesem Film.
Das ist wirklich egal. Jeder Po besagt,
ich komme schon wieder runter.
Was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass ein Satellit war, was damals von Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, Po besagt, wir kommen schon wieder runter. Ja, ja. Nee, was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass ein Satellit, der damals von Elon Musk ins Weltall geschossen wurde, ihm aus der Kontrolle geraten ist. Da gab es einen Fehler, der sollte so ein GPS-Satellit, und der rast seitdem um die Erde und knallte jetzt bald, wurde errechnet, auf den Mond. Ja? Mit einer unfassbaren Geschwindigkeit, dass Experten sagen, dass dann ein Krater, ein kleiner Krater entsteht. Fucking Experten! Aber das muss man sich mal vorstellen, ne? Dass wir den Mond beeinflussen auf so eine Art, gefällt mir gar nicht. Ja, vor allem, das ist ja schwer, den zu treffen, den Mond. Selbst wenn du ihn treffen willst, ist es ja manchmal leid. Und ich glaube, es ist nur kein Skandal, weil er schon sehr viele Krater hat. So, he is seen worse. Wäre der noch komplett glatt. Stell dir mal vor, der wäre glatt. So eine perfekte Marmor-Oberfläche. Genau, so eine Murmel, so eine Eis-Murmel, so eine glatte Murmel. Und plötzlich unser Menschen gemacht, das Satellit, setzt da so rein und dann hast du so einen Riss, so Fadenrisse, die sich so erstrecken. Ja, oder so ein soer Fleck. Und immer erinnert dich dieser Himmelskörper daran, dass wir fucking Idioten sind.
Ja.
Das wär schlimm.
Ja. Und dann hast du so einen Riss, so Fadenrisse, die sich so erstrecken. Ja, oder so ein soer Fleck. Und immer erinnert dich dieser Himmelskörper daran, dass wir fucking Idioten sind.
Ja.
Das wäre schlimm.
Aber er hat, weil seine ganze Oberfläche sagt, ich habe alles gesehen.
Leute, Leute.
Ihr könnt mir nicht mehr wehtun.
Leute, Eidon.
Nee, wirklich, ihr könnt mir nicht wehtun.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Es ist der tote, grosse Brocken mit den tausend Kratern, deswegen ist es egal.
Ja, aber das ist halt, wer keine Atmosphäre hat, kriegt Krater. Das ist leider die kosmische Realität, in der wir leben. Also, schafft euch eine Atmosphäre an, gefälligst ... Schafft euch eine dicke Atmosphäre an, damit ihr keine Krater erleiden müsst. Und denkt nochmal drüber nach, über erstens Stephans Idee mit der Abschaffung von Städten. Jetzt, wenn du es so sagst. Zweitens natürlich nochmal zum Thema, was es geht in Afrika, Vorsicht, falls ihr das wisst, dann schickt uns einen kleinen Beitrag darüber und ansonsten denkt man einfach nochmal drüber nach.
Denkt mal generell, da ist alles nach.
Geht mal in euch, haut rein, wir wünschen euch eine ganz, ganz tolle Woche, bis nächste Woche, dann sind wir einmal um die Erde gekreist und kommen wieder.
Ja, denn so funktioniert die Erde gekreist.
Mach's gut.
Ciao!